l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale de Monsieur Jean-Claude Lenoir à
Monsieur Miss de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues je souhaite appeler
l'attention du gouvernement sur les
problèmes posés par l'extension des
zones vulnérables au titre de la
pollution du haut nitrate
la France
conduite en cela par des pressions
fortes de Bruxelles
procède à la cinquième révision de la
carte des zones vulnérables suite à une
directive qui était adoptée en 1991 donc
c'est la directive nitrate qui est
actualisée
il se trouve que cette zone va être
agrandie d'une façon spectaculaire
et que donc un certain nombre de
territoires ruraux notamment des terres
d'élevage vont être particulièrement
touchés
il faut comprendre que
un critère a été introduit dans le
dispositif qui a été retenu par le
gouvernement c'est le trophée des eaux
côtières
de ce fait des territoires qui se font
assez éloigner de la côte en ce qui me
concerne le département de l'Orne en est
éloigné d'une centaine de kilomètres
vont être touchés par ces dispositions
alors que jusqu'à présent les terres qui
étaient retenues étaient celles dont le
taux de nitrate par litre était
supérieur à 40 ou 50 mg
on observe que des territoires dont ce
taux est supérieur à 18 voire à 12 vont
être concernés
donc il y a l'extension du territoire et
de ce roi il y a gravation des
contraintes notamment pour ce qui est de
la période pendant laquelle les pandases
est autorisé et d'autre part pour ce qui
concerne le stockage des effluents
d'origine animale avec évidemment un
coup élevé pour les éleveurs qui ont
déjà dû faire face à des contraintes qui
ont pesé très lourd sur le bilan de leur
exploitation à titre d'exemple pour un
troupeau de 40 vaches laitières moins de
UGB le coût de la mise au norme va
s'élever d'après les simulations que
j'ai faites entre 50 5 et 85000 euros et
pour un troupeau de 40 vaches
allaitantes c'est entre 35 et 55000
euros or ces contraintes vont peser sur
plutôt des petites exploitations parce
que les plus importantes ont déjà eu
l'occasion et le temps de financer ces
nouvelles installations
et donc aujourd'hui ce sont plutôt les
petits éleveurs qui vont être victimes
de cette
disposition j'ai écrit au ministre après
avoir déposé cette question orale qui
remonte au mois d'octobre depuis un
certain nombre de choses sont produites
j'ai écrit au ministre qui m'a répondu
au mois de janvier me disant bon qu'il y
aurait des financements je suis
extrêmement intéressé à connaître les
financements dont il s'agit ainsi que
connaître le degré de mobilisation du
gouvernement sur cette question qui si
elle n'était pas réglée toucherait de
façon extrêmement grave quantité de
territoires consacrée à l'élevage
merci la parole est à la miamina
Benguigui chargée de la Francophonie
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Jean-Claude Lenoir je tiens
tout d'abord à excuser Stéphane Le Foll
ministre de l'Agriculture qui est retenu
pour répondre à la question orale à
l'Assemblée nationale ce matin vous
interrogez le gouvernement sur
l'application de la directive nitrate il
convient tout d'abord de rappeler que
les États membres de l'Union européenne
se sont engagés au titre de la directive
nitrate dès 1991
à établir des programmes d'action afin
de réduire la pollution des eaux
provoquer ou induite par les nitrates à
partir de sources agricoles et de
prévenir toute nouvelle pollution de ce
type en particulier dans les zones dites
vulnérables la directive fixe les
mesures qui doivent être incluses dans
les programmes les récentes évolutions
réglementaires relatives à l'application
de la directive et la révision des zones
vulnérables s'inscrivent dans le cadre
de deux procédures contentieuses
intentées par la Commission européenne
contre la France auprès de la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne pour
mauvaises applications de la directive
d'une part et délimitations
insuffisantes des zones vulnérables des
quatre bassins à Dour Garonne Loire
Bretagne reins Meuse et rones
Méditerranée d'autre part s'agiss ant de
la délimitation des zones vulnérables la
révision engagée en 2012 s'est achevé
par la prise des arrêts modificatifs en
décembre et le et début janvier à la
suite d'une concertation avec tous les
acteurs concernés
il convient de relativiser l'impact de
ce nouveau classement en zone vulnérable
au total
1440 communes entre dans le zonage
tandis que 617 en sorte ce qui
correspond à une augmentation globale de
4,3% des communes classées
le critère d'euros tropisation marine
qui soulève l'opposition de la
profession agricole fait entrer dans le
zonage seulement
204 communes soit 1% des communes
classées ce nouveau zonage devrait
répondre aux exigences de la commission
évitant ainsi des classements
supplémentaires et disproportionnées
s'agissant du contenu des cinquième
programme d'action les premiers
renforcements initiés par le programme
d'action nationale entrée en vigueur en
septembre dernier on fait l'objet d'une
concertation approfondie avec les
représentants de la profession agricole
il convient dans cet exercice de
concilier les exigences imposées par la
directive avec le respect des principes
agronomiques qui doivent continuer de
régir la mise en oeuvre de cette
directive en France les programmes
d'action régionaux
élaborer en région au premier semestre
2013 nous sommes dans la phase de
concertation
aucune nouvelle mesure n'a encore été
prise à ce stade l'heure est à la
mobilisation responsable de tous les
acteurs concernés s'agissant du stockage
des influents d'élevage il est prévu de
préciser et compléter les mesures du
programme d'action nationale dans un
nouvel arrêté la concertation sur ce
projet de texte a été ouverte fin
septembre
l'objectif du gouvernement et de
défendre une approche la plus adaptée
possible aux besoins agronomiques de
chaque système d'exploitation le
ministre de l'Agriculture s'attache en
outre à défendre les possibilités de
stockage aux champs de certains
effluents qui n'ont pas d'incidence
négatives sur l'environnement le
gouvernement a donc maintenu cette
mesure dans le cadre de la réforme
réglementaire ce qui permet à une grande
partie des élèves des élevages bovins de
ne pas avoir à faire d'investissement
supplément faire pour le stockage des
fions d'élevage d'autre part vous
m'interrogez sur l'aide aux
investissements je peux vous rassurer
dans la mesure où les investissements
nécessaires pour la mise aux normes des
exploitations dans les nouvelles zones
vulnérables ainsi que pour
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
pendant un délai de 36 mois pourront
faire l'objet des financements
le ministère de l'écologie devrait
pouvoir établir le soutien que pourrait
apporter les agences de l'eau en
parallèle le ministre de l'Agriculture
tenait à rappeler qu'il attache une
importance particulière à
l'accompagnement de ces mises au normes
et que le gouvernement est mobilisé pour
défendre les élevages à l'herbe et
utiliser toutes les possibilités pour
prendre en compte les spécificités et
les bénéfices environnementaux de ce
type d'élevage en conclusion monsieur le
sénateur il est indispensable de bien
comprendre que la concertation engagée
par le gouvernement devra conduire à des
mesures à la fois
acceptables par la Commission dans le
cas dans le cadre d'un contentieux à
haut risque financiers et qui pourrait
nous imposer des mesures en
contradiction avec l'esprit de
proportionnalité dans lequel nous
travaillons jusqu'à présent
et pragmatique d'un point de vue
agronomique pour être accepté par la
profession agricole dans un contexte
économique très difficile
le noir
je vous remercie des pressions que vous
avez apportées je remercie le ministre
de l'Agriculture qui vous a fourni cette
réponse pour autant mon inquiétude n'a
pas diminué vous me permettrez de vous
l'exprimer
permettez moi d'abord de vous dire que
les acteurs que sont les agriculteurs
sont parfaitement responsables
effectivement ils savent qu'ils doivent
s'engager dans des actions visant à
diminuer les pollutions notamment
d'origine animale de ce point de vue là
leur engagement est total et constant
depuis déjà de nombreuses années cela
dit la concertation dont vous parlez a
plus reprise dans votre réponse n'est
pas perçue c'est pas le mot qui vient à
l'esprit de ceux qui ont éventuellement
participé à des réunions auxquelles se
retrouvaient d'ailleurs beaucoup plus de
représentants des services de l'État que
de représentants de la profession cette
concertation n'a pas laissé des
souvenirs très très forts dans l'esprit
des gens qui attendaient des réponses
aux questions qu'il posait
alors maintenant la vraie question
madame la ministre et la suivante est-ce
qu'il est justifié que des territoires
où le taux de nitrates et de l'ordre ce
que je vous ai indiqué tout à l'heure de
12 à 18 mg par litre alors que la
référence était jusqu'à présent de 40 à
50 puissent être concernés par ces zones
dites vulnérables
deuxièmement la vraie question
aujourd'hui c'est quel financement alors
le ministre d'agriculture m'avait écrit
pour
tenter de me rassurer j'ai retrouvé les
formules dans votre réponse
je n'ai pas trouvé dans le budget du
ministère d'agriculture de linze
spécifique qui permettent de participer
au financement de ces mises aux normes
est-ce qu'on va pas prendre de l'argent
sur une autre ligne est-ce que
finalement globalement nous n'allons pas
nous retrouver devant une insuffisance
de crédit la question est majeure
enfin je voudrais vous dire en
conclusion que j'étais parfaite
particulièrement frappé de voir le
découragement qui s'est dit aujourd'hui
les éleveurs
on voit une tendance très forte
retournement des prairies c'est-à-dire
on transforme les terres des signal
élevage en terre pour
accueillir des céréales et se
découragement atteint notamment les plus
jeunes agriculteurs on voit qu'il y a
maintenant une hésitation pour des
jeunes à s'engager et un renoncement
pour des jeunes qui s'étaient assez il
n'y a pas très longtemps et qui
préfèrent vendre leur cheptel et se
consacrer plutôt à des activités
céréales hier voir à d'autres activités
il y va madame les ministres et je suis
persuadé que vous transmettrez au
ministre de l'Agriculture ces
observations il y va vraiment de
l'avenir de l'élevage français élevage
auquel nous sommes attachés compte tenu
de la qualité de nos produits je vous